[موسيقى]
ا
ب
[موسيقى]
ايده
[موسيقى]
ح
apaa
[موسيقى]
انا فاطمه رقف الظاهر خريجه اداب لغه
عربيه من جامعه الاقصى تزوجت محمود من
اربع سنوات فكره قديش هو بعرض نفسه ممكن
للخطر على شان يوفر الحاجات مش موجوده
مثلا الاكل والشرب احنا يعني بنمر في شد
وضع عشنا فيه بحياتنا من ناحيه فقر في
الاكل والشرب واللزمات الاساسيه في يوم من
الايام يعني من فتره قريبه جدا يعني
استيقظت بنته كانت بتعيط بدها تاكل واحن
ما كان عننا ولا ذره طحين في البيت في
الماوى ف طلع هو يعني بغيب بيطلع بالساعات
وبطول فيعني انا كنت كثير قلانه وين راح
وين فهو كان بيجي المساعدات بشكل مقنن جدا
وبتم يعني توزيعها بشكل مش عن طريق كشوفات
ومش عن لا رمي المساعدات
في مناطق ممكن تكون خطره جدا لكن محمود
حاحاول انه هو حاول انه هو يقرب من هذه
المناطق وبالفعل عرض حاله يعني للموت
ويومها كان في اكثر من 25 شهيد يعني القيت
عليه من القذائف من دبابات والحمد لله
اللي ربنا سلمه يعني وجاب كيس طحين بس
عشان هو شافها هي بتعيط وهي بدها تاكل
فهذه الجوانب يعني ظهرت بشكل كبير في
الحرب يعني انا اكيد بعرف انه محمود هيك
بس يعني كان الشيء بزياده بزياده
[موسيقى]
para